[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm Constance in kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
contributing editor at City Journal and
the host of the podcast conversations
with Coleman Coleman who's we've been
looking forward to this for a long time
welcome to trigonometry glad to be here
it's so good to have your man for anyone
who doesn't know who you are just give
us a little brief overview of who you
are how are you where you are what is
the journey that brings you here talking
to us I yea grew up in New Jersey most
of you know I was you know always good
in school but mostly into music as a kid
briefly went to Julliard out of out of
high school with the intent of becoming
a professional jazz musician but then
things change it changed and priorities
change and I ended up at Columbia doing
a degree in philosophy which I finished
about a month ago and during my time at
Columbia started writing for various
online outlets on issues of race and
racial inequality politics and other odd
issues here and there usually in the
American context all right well he's
brilliant to have you your work and your
writing has been quite sensational and
exceptional I've been following it for
some time we all have I think but let me
let me take us back to 2008 because I
remember that moment very well I
remember work exactly where I was you
know it was a Barack Obama gets elected
this brilliant charismatic leader who
seems to you know assemble a very large
coalition you know most of the United
States most of the world is celebrating
the fact that you have the first black
president and what a president too is
articulate he's intelligent he's capable
he's inspiring I was know calling him
articulate that's a microaggression he's
a skilled orator
in a very non-racial way right you know
I remember that moment I think many
people will remember that how inspired
they felt because what I think a lot of
people felt was here we are finally it
does not matter what your skin color is
you do whoever you are you can rise to
the top and you can succeed if you've
got the talent to do it this is the end
of the racist past that we've had what
happened well even more useful is to
roll it back to say 2007 and ask
virtually any black person in America
whether Barack Obama could make it the
answer you would get is almost uniformly
no we're not ready and the reason people
said that is because they knew if he won
it would mean that we had made
significant deep progress on the issue
of racism and they did not think we
hadn't made that progress and therefore
believe that Barack couldn't win now a
strange thing happened when Barack did
win which is that virtually nobody
updated their views of how much progress
we've made as a country which doesn't
make very much sense usually when you
make a prediction based on your model of
the world and your prediction gets
completely destroyed by reality you're
supposed to update your model of the
world to come back in line with what's
actually happening people didn't do that
with Barack they should have so there
was a moment where obviously conscience
I mentioned where he Barack Obama got
elected the yes we can speech everything
like that why has it suddenly distorted
into where we find ourselves now is it
do you think just one reason in
particular other am i read of different
reasons do you mean the perception of
racism why has it gotten so much worse
in the past 10 years
absolutely well yeah I think that social
media has a lot to do with it what in
2008 when Barack was elected not so many
people were on Facebook somewhere but it
wasn't what it is now not obviously
Twitter
was barely a thing Instagram much less
people didn't you know smartphones were
not ubiquitous I still had a flip phone
at that time so what that means is in
2008 when an unarmed American gets shot
by the cops which probably happened
around 50 or a hundred times that year
we don't have good data from back then
you know many of those would have been
white some of those would have been
black nobody saw a video of it in their
newsfeed if it happened in Kentucky it
stayed in a local Kentucky newspaper
never made it to the New York Times or
The Washington Post of the Wall Street
Journal and people's what people saw on
their news on the news was you know a
black man getting elected to president
so you know that that's where people get
their perception from by and large now
you moved to 2012 or 2014 the biggest
shift that has taken place has nothing
to do with the presidency Barack Obama
has won his second term handily over
over a strong a rather strong candidate
and Mitt Romney but what's different now
is everyone has an iPhone or smartphone
rather everyone's on Facebook and
Twitter so that when Michael Brown or
falando castile or Alton sterling dies
at the hand of the cops unarmed we are
all confronted with this for the first
time in a visceral way you see it
there's a huge difference between a
story staying and local news in Kentucky
which is what happens to 99% of
tragedies that occur throughout the
nation and being confronted with it no
matter where you are in the country on
the news cycle 24/7 on your phone on
your face in your Facebook feed where
all your friends you know people whose
approval you care about are commenting
on it and now you feel pressure to
have an opinion at minimum that creates
an entirely different social dynamic and
what I want to what is most important to
glean here is that all of the actual
problems if you're talking about
for example police killing unarmed
Americans in general or unarmed black
Americans in particular if you're
talking about the number of black
Americans in prison all of these issues
have been going in completely the right
direction for the past 20 years
most people don't know for example that
the incarceration rate for black black
men in their 20s has more than cut in
half since 2001 most people don't know
that just in the past five years that
we've been measuring police killings of
unarmed Americans it's gone down from
you know almost a hundred to just over
50 and you know the the data is not good
here but the like NYPD has kept great
data since the 70s and they killed like
93 people unarmed or perhaps not unarmed
but in total in 1971 and they had it
down to five by last year so you know
every one of these questions has gone in
the right direction sometimes quickly
and drastically but the perception is
that it's gone in the opposite direction
that things have gotten worse and that
that is entirely the result of social
media I think some people are tempted to
blame it on Obama I think people are too
hard on Obama yeah sometimes he played a
bit of identity politics but in truth
you know I don't think he had he
couldn't have predicted the effect that
Twitter and Facebook and the rest were
going to have on the country and on the
perception of racism well I think that
was actually one of the things that
inspired someone like me about his
campaign at the time is that there was
no sense at all that he was using his
identity as a weapon suddenly he wasn't
pretending he wasn't black but he wasn't
using that as a way to to claim
additional credit or whatever he was
just a guy who was very inspiring to a
lot of people and you know his politics
aside is is a slightly different issue
as a personality I think
he was it was very persuasive in that
way but if he I mean you say that all of
these we've made up moves in the right
direction and all these issues but is
there not an argument there to say that
okay well maybe it's 50 people who died
unarmed at the hands of the police now
but that's still way too many and what
we've seen is the proliferation of the
camera phone it has shown a light on you
know genuine police brutality that
should not be happening at all and you
know the outrage we see now is justified
as a response to us becoming aware of
genuine injustice I mean you know the
George Floyd example which I'm sure
we'll get on to being a perfect example
of just an open-and-shut case of police
brutality so here we have to be very
careful about what we're talking about
if we're talking about George Floyd and
an officer putting his knee on the neck
of a suspect for nine minutes while he
begs for his life begs for his mother
that is something I think we can
completely get rid of you know I think
it has to be possible to enforce some
kind of policy that permanently prevents
things like that from happening or if
they do happen they happen you know once
every ten years and it's a scandal and
that cop gets fired immediately and it's
you know it's it's one of those freaking
news stories um you know the same thing
happened to a white man named Tony Tim
but in 2016 very few people paid
attention it was caught on video almost
an identical incident he was he was
killed
suffocated with a neon on his upper back
begging for his life so that that's the
kind of thing I think I hope it's
possible to completely eradicate but if
we want to talk about the wider
phenomenon of a cop killing a person
while unarmed there are a lot of reality
checks that we have to we have to keep
in mind before we we jump to the idea
that the number ought to be zero okay
like I would love for the number to be
zero I think everyone would I would also
love for the number of murders in
general to be zero it's never happened
in any society ever
and America is a particularly unique
case for a couple of reasons one we're a
huge country
we're ten times the size of Canada
population wise which means that
extremely low probability events happen
ten times as often here as they do in
somewhere like Canada if Canada were
identical to the US so it can seem like
something you know lightning will people
will die from lightning strikes more
often here secondly and more importantly
we are a gun country we are a huge gun
country we have you know a rate of gun
ownership that's more than twenty times
the rate in the UK and what that means
is when the cops in America pull someone
over they have every reason to suspect
and and and be prepared for the fact
that they have a pistol hidden in the
glove compartment and that's just not
true in other countries in the UK when
you pull someone over you have almost no
reason to suspect that they might have a
gun because so few people do have guns a
cop get shot roughly every every single
day in America and what that means is in
America the cops are always going to be
more likely to mistake a wallet for a
gun when unarmed person reaches in their
waistband for something and and this
happens to white people as well all the
time it's just you know they never get
elevated to national news they're
probably over a dozen cases like this
every year and I don't see realistically
how any amount of training or you know
any amount of reform is going to get rid
of the problem that that police are
aware that a cop gets shot every day in
this country unlike in other countries
and that in the heat of the moment you
often actually cannot tell whether
something is a smartphone or a wallet so
what I'm saying is is yes I think we can
probably get the number from what it was
last year which is about 56 we can
probably reduce that but we absolutely
cannot reduce it to zero and that's very
important because
if the future of race relations or the
future of civilian cop trust depends on
that number being zero then we are
absolutely doomed as a country and
common we've been talking about whose
stereo on social media how it gets
whipped up how then you know it distorts
reality what responsibility does Trump
have to take because I've been certain
tweets we've done he's done which have
been to put it quite frankly
inflammatory and not gonna help the
situation absolutely yeah Trump he's
seen it almost seems as if he's trying
to say the thing that is going to piss
the left off as much as possible or piss
black people off as much as possible I
mean he could do slightly worse but he
couldn't do that much worse
realistically I think there's no doubt
that he has added some fuel to the fire
of the protests and the riots and in in
many ways he thrives in this condition
because every far-left access when when
people on the Left say they're you know
they're gonna get rid of dismantle or
defund the police Trump comes to look
actually sane by comparison when he
makes people go insane become as insane
as him it gives people the impression
that well yeah Trump is insane but the
far left is insane - and maybe Trump's
our only bet so he really he really
thrives in this circumstance
he certainly has added fuel to the fire
what you would want is right now as a
president who can be a unifying force
and Trump is constitutionally incapable
of that at the same time the the riots
and the the underlying distress that
we're feeling as a country is not caused
by Trump these are perennial issues we
have rise in the late 60s riots in the
70s not so many in the 80s but huge rise
in 1992 riots in Ferguson and Baltimore
2014 and 2015 under Obama and Obama
would have been you know ostensibly the
perfect president to stop it but the
truth is the issues are much deeper than
any particular president
interests in common let me ask you this
because you've used several times now
you've talked about the white suspect
who died in similar circumstances to
George George Floyd and see even though
you said his name and I'm familiar with
it I can't remember it now which is kind
of bizarre a loose mind yeah racist
against white people obviously but this
kind of makes you a point which is you
know we don't treat these instances in
the same way why is that well that's a
very deep question
I think deep in the American
subconscious you know many of us have
seen the videos of police putting the
hoses and the dogs on perfectly peaceful
civil rights protesters in the 1960s who
are simply asking for the right to vote
the right to go to a restaurant and
we've seared those images into our
subconscious and they they form part of
how we make sense of morality and right
and wrong and when an American and
probably probably true of many Europeans
as well sees a white cop doing something
to a black suspect they feel differently
and they feel angrier then if a white
cop had done it to a white suspect or
frankly if a black cop had done it to a
black suspect it hits harder it tugs at
one's heartstrings hold a little bit
more in fact a lot more even if it's the
identical crime and this is this is a
deep it's a deep kind of moral confusion
that we have but it's extremely hard to
root out because ultimately a life is a
life that if that's not true nothing is
true but we just we're just hardwired to
feel well I shouldn't say hardwired
where our software our cultural software
as Americans makes us feel that a racist
crime there's there's a particular edge
that that has in in our feelings that
intra-racial violence doesn't have so
that's why you see you know in fact
there are dozens of their videos of like
people getting killed by the cops with
their hands up begging for their lives
every bit as brutal and and terrifying
and awful as the videos we've seen you
know there's this whole at all the black
lives matter protest there's this thing
you know
you know I say say their name when you
say the name Alton sterling falando
Castille Tamir rice Sandra bland Michael
Brown Eric garner etc there are so many
white names there are in fact in
absolute terms there are more white
names and there are black names and I've
spent some time looking at them and
they're they're identical the case is
for every black person killed by the
police there are you know usually two or
three white people that died died
exactly the same way
nobody says their names and nobody cares
that's that seems to people like the
correct moral bias because we're
imprinted with the symbolism of the
civil rights movement but we have to
outgrow this if we're going to be a
cohesive country going into the 21st
century which is you know a very
different reality than where we're
coming from the interesting thing about
this movement and particularly murder of
George Floyd was it doesn't obviously it
hasn't affected America it's turned into
this global movement why do you think
that is common why do you think that
people in the UK and Australia in Brazil
were there having huge BLM rallies why
is it that people have really connected
with them with this particular crime
that is a fascinating question I've
already given my rant on social media
and you know I think no doubt that has
something to do with it I love how long
describe it is around you're so
mild-mannered and kind that your common
gentle description of your concerns
about social media becomes a run I love
it
but do you know I think probably
coronavirus has something to do with it
to imagine people around the world are
working much less than usual in their
house much more than usual on Facebook
Twitter and watching the news much more
than usual
are more restless and bored than usual
all of those things conspire I think to
make people more likely to go out and
protest and do you think the I mean this
is my fear of it because you know I've
got a lot of friends like in the UK were
black and they're talking about their
experiences and from growing up and
they're in their 30s and they've got and
they're talking about what it's like to
be a black man in South London in the
nineties when the police were really
racist do you think part of this is just
unearthing some deep trauma within
people from using years back like my mum
came to this country from Venezuela
she's a brown woman and very
conservative very very right-wing but
she doesn't like police and I didn't
expect that response for her she was
saying police a racist so do you think
it's just this trauma that a lot of
people are covering and one of a sudden
they get a chance to expunge it almost
absolutely I think there are decades and
decades you know we can talk about to
what extent the cops are racist today in
2020 but there's no doubt that for you
know I know less about London's history
but I definitely take take your mother's
experience as probably true of a lot of
people there's no doubt that there's
just decades and decades of accumulated
bad faith between the police and in
particular the black community for
disproportionately stopping black and
Hispanic people men especially you know
planting drugs on suspects all kinds of
corruption and lying and brutality
there's just decades of accumulated
experience with that and that all of
that gets symbolically discharged when
an event like this happens it's not just
about George Floyd for people it's about
the whole history of of brutal policing
going back many decades and ultimately
the history of white supremacy
going back to slavery I do think there's
a danger in making an issue symbolic
like that because then you you kind of
decide what you think about the George
Floyd incident before you've actually
looked to you its if it's really about
whether the police in Brooklyn or South
Central LA were racist in 1990 which I
have no doubt that they were if that's
what decides your your decision your
opinion on George Floyd in 2020 and
black lives matter and the degree to
which the cops are racist now then then
we're just having two separate
conversations and it becomes very
difficult you know then facts facts
cease to matter in the now but I can
totally understand why someone you know
we all bring all of our our whole life
history with us and the police have a
horrible history they made a lot of
progress and put a you know another way
to frame that is that they use days to
be far far worse and a lot of people
remember it and they resent it and you
talked about the different ways we treat
these instances when depending on what
what race of victim is involved do you
think there is an element where there
are assumptions that are made if the if
the suspect who dies is black which
aren't necessarily I mean they may be
accurate but they may not like is there
any evidence at the moment George Floyd
was his murder is racially motivated do
we know that the short answer is no it's
one of those things that I want to be
clear about what I'm saying we don't
have a reason to believe that it was
racist right it could have been racist
that's exactly what I'm saying it may
well cost deeply racist but they don't
know that but I think there's some
justice I don't know it was right yes
and the reason they make that assessment
assessment is because the vast majority
of people they haven't seen all the
videos of white people being killed in
this way they haven't seen the Tony Tim
the video where the same thing happened
to a white guy a few years ago and so
they assume because this kind of thing
overwhelmingly or only happens
black people that therefore it's racist
still I'm sure even if you showed them
all the videos of it happening to white
people a certain kind of person will say
no I just know it in my bones I know it
I know that you wouldn't have done that
to a white boy and you can't argue with
that because it's its faith at that
point and let's move on to the
organization of black lives matter now I
think we everybody agree with it of
course black lives do matter of course
they do and it's important that we end
police brutality of course it is
or essentially you know try and minimize
it like you said as much as possible but
why is it that we have this organization
someone and you I've read through that
you know what what they want to achieve
you know the abolition of the nuclear
family defunding the police and lots of
other things and it makes you deeply
deeply uncomfortable but it does for me
because of my background as a Venezuelan
why is it that you can't criticize black
lives matter the organization
well what they've what they've done
which is you know what all successful
propagandists do is to have a very a
very indisputable you know facial
argument by which I mean who wouldn't
agree that black lives matter like if
you if you actually disagree with that
taken literally you're a monster hmm
right so on the one hand they could say
oh we're just all we're saying is that
black lives matter and then when you say
but wait a minute what about that
abolishing the nuclear family things
they can always retrieve to say listen
we're about black lives mattering you're
active you're either with that or you're
not and then they hide all of these
other much more radical much more
controversial much less defensible
claims but you know I it's also we're
stating that black lives matter is not
like the civil rights movement it's the
civil rights movement was pretty
coherent they had a set of you know
goals that there was a top-down
structure
so the organization that you know made
it made it you know it made sense to
talk about it as one body but black
lives matter they have chapters all over
the nation the people protesting with
that slogan many of them don't believe
this stuff that you find on the you know
the National website about abolishing
the nuclear family you know a lot of
that is coming from the higher-ups that
always have an incentive to go for the
more and more radical thing whereas I
think I've been to a couple of these
protests and I yeah I think there are
some folks who really go all the way
with it and but there are others that
are just there because you know they saw
the video they were moved by it and they
think something has to be done about
police brutality so I'm always wary of
painting with too broad a brush but yeah
that would be my answer to that so so
what is your assessment of the impact of
the black lives matters as an
organization or as a movement do you see
it as a forceful kid in part I think you
know I'm not if not for black lives
matter I'm not sure how much we'd be
talking about police reform right now
would we be talking about ending the
legal doctrine of qualified immunity
which which makes it tough to bring
civil rights lawsuits against police
officers probably not would we be
talking about universal body cams you
know not funding the use of
military-grade weapons to go to police
departments all these strike me has
probably good ideas and I'm not sure
we'd be talking about them frankly I'm
not even sure we would have a national
database on police shootings which we
didn't actually have until 2015 and we
still don't have an official government
around the database so all of that is to
the good and I think black lives matter
deserves credit for at the same time the
central premise of their movement is not
true
the idea that we have a problem with
racist cops killing unarmed black people
and
it's a dangerous myth because it's a
kind of myth that if you believe it it
makes sense to go out and riot and
destroy businesses and loot and set
things on fire if it's really true that
the state is uniquely coming after your
people and shooting them dead that's the
kind of thing that leads people to riot
and that's the narrative we've been sold
for the past roughly seven years let's
say and then the nation started burning
and I don't know who else to blame but
the people who spread this myth and
where do you stand I know I can guess
what the answer is going to be so for
instance I talked to some of my friends
more towards the left the progressive
level and I say look you know I think
it's important that we have these
discussions of course I disagree with
rioting and burning down businesses and
I got described as having using the
language of an Israeli or an occupier
which was delightful but there we go
lovely way to spend the tuesday
afternoon coleman um where do you stand
on this and people who say the only way
that we can achieve something is by
rioting and looting historically
illiterate i think you know some people
will think that that's naive but there
there's a little something called the
Civil Rights Act of 1964 and the Voting
Rights Act of 1965 I don't remember a
violent a single violent thing that
protesters did to achieve that the riots
we had in the 60s didn't really start in
earnest until 1967 that was after the
great civil rights legislative reforms
Martin Luther King's moving it was a
peaceful movement on purpose
the police were violent but the whole
point was that no matter how violent the
police got the protesters would never
get violent and they would win over the
hearts and minds of America by showing
them how peaceful they were how
committed to their principles they were
what did the what did the violent
protests of the late 60s achieved
certainly nothing on par with the
Rights Act in the Civil Rights Act as I
as I said you know progress progress
usually doesn't come in the form of some
sexy legislation that happens after you
burn half of your country down actually
usually progress happens a little bit
every day and after at the end of the 20
at the end of 20 years you say holy [ __ ]
there are half as many black people in
prison as they were in 2001 or young
young black men in this case but of
course no one pays attention to that so
they get the impression that nothing has
changed they're just watching the news
every day they're not looking at numbers
because nobody does and and then they
get this false impression that that
violence is the only way you can make
progress I'll give another example the
first step act it's a little piece of
legislation that nobody paid attention
to because frankly because it felt well
here's what happened
you know Trump ran a campaign saying he
was gonna build a wall and you know we
were a lot of people were afraid he was
gonna put Muslims on a kind of registry
or something and frankly we didn't
really know whether he was gonna be a
Hitler or you know just like a kind of
petty authoritarian wannabe
authoritarian frankly I didn't know
because I didn't know how much of it was
talk and how much of it was was for real
and I voted against him largely worried
about the small chance that he would end
up being a kind of true Hitler figure
hmm then he got to power in 2018 you
know he passes a you know a bipartisan
bill that includes every progressive
criminal justice reform that people on
the far left have been calling for since
2007 called a first step act he you know
releases a couple thousand you know
inmates from federal prison reduce his
sentences for a couple thousand more you
know the majority of these people are
black it it
it's the focus from punishment to
rehabilitation it's just everything that
you wouldn't expect a sort of law and
order politician like Trump to do and of
course he got no credit for it because
it was too awkward and surprising to
sort of admit that he did something like
that but that was exactly the kind of
progress that if it had come after a
riot people would have seen it as proof
that riots work you know but because it
just came sort of out of the blue in the
middle of in the middle of Trump's first
tournament people just didn't even pay
attention to it my point here being that
progress is happening all the time it's
not that it needs riots to happen is
that all the people justifying the riots
they're not paying attention when the
progress is happening Amen the riots
have achieved something we're tearing
down statues in this country over
something that happened in your country
so they're making progress in one way or
another but let's talk about I mean look
as you as you say there are some
legitimate complaints and of course
there's some legitimate positive
outcomes out of what black lives matter
are doing and I suppose the central
complaint you you bring up the you know
white victims versus black victims the
the central complaint would be the black
people are disproportionately imprisoned
black people are disproportionately
stopped black people are
disproportionately searched black people
are disproportionately the victims of
police brutality etc and and as far as I
know all those things are true if you
just look at the they're all statistics
black people about 13% of the population
but much more represented than that and
all those other categories so are those
not legitimate claims well no because
you know as any intro stats student will
tell you you you've got of you've got to
control for the confounding variables
you know men make up more than 90% of
victims in all these cases whether
you're talking about brutality prison
shot by the cops or otherwise men are of
course only 50% of the population just
viewing that fact doesn't tell you
anything about anti male bias per se
you have to think about you know and
it's impossible not to talk about the
underlying facts of racially disparate
crime 13% of the population commits and
suffers 52% of the murders and you know
that that's probably the largest
disparity but if you're talking about
robberies aggravated assaults you know
the all of the virtually all of the
disparities except you know drunk
driving and a few others show black
people showing up black men young black
men in particular showing up heavily
heavily disproportionate rates and
that's a first order problem the police
are coming into contact with young black
men far far more often as a result even
if they didn't pay attention to skin
color at all and I'm not saying there is
no racial bias in the police I think
there is I think some of that is just
some of it's just good old-fashioned
racism some of it is the fact that you
know if I were a cop in New York where
roughly 97% of the shootings every year
97% are committed and suffered by blacks
and Hispanics that means you could
forget the white part of that and almost
not even make a dent in the total number
of shootings is it possible that I would
develop a kernel of racial bias which is
to say when I see a black or Hispanic
suspect I suspect him more than I would
a white person I would love to say that
I'm such an amazing human being that I
wouldn't develop that but I'm also not
naive and I don't want to be such a such
a self flattering backseat driver to the
cops whose job it is to actually keep
everyone safe including black and
Hispanic people the vast majority of
whom do not commit crime even in the
most criminal neighborhoods so you have
to look at you know virtually every
study I've looked at that controls for
all of these variables finds no
anti-black bias in deadly shootings
sometimes they find anti black biases in
cops likelihood to put his hands on and
rough up a suspect and that's a very
real problem but they're simply there's
really no disparity to be found when it
comes to a cops decision to pull the
trigger all right but what about this
idea that this is still all down to
racism because it's a result of the fact
that black people tend to be poorer and
they're poorer because of the history
and the legacy of Jim Crow it's a legacy
of slavery because a lot of black people
are the descendants of slaves they don't
have the same economic base therefore
they live in poorer neighborhoods
therefore there's more crime therefore
they're still being punished for
essentially being brought to America
it's late I think it's a very
superficial analysis of what causes
people to commit crime I suppose it's a
very long conversation you know if I
talk to someone who well let me put it
this way if you look at the history of
the you know American crime rate over
the past hundred years and your theory
is that poverty causes crime you're
gonna run into a lot of awkward facts
like you know when the economy is
booming crime doesn't always go down
sometimes it goes up you know during the
recession 2008 crime went down why is
that on a theory that says poverty
causes crime that there should have been
a huge uptick I think the truth is much
more complicated I think did this gets
into very different this gets into your
picture of human nature and why someone
would commit crime to begin with and
there begins to be such a huge gap in
worldview that that it's sort of hard to
settle in the course of a single
conversation but suffice it to say I
don't really look for reasons why
someone commits a crime to me what we
call a quote-unquote criminal behavior
for much of our species existence would
have just been behavior like yeah you
kill someone from the other tribe he's
in another gang [ __ ] him
it's not that much more complicated than
that it's and it doesn't have to be
because you grew up poor rich people
commit crimes to when they all the
people on Wall Street money laundering
and defrauding investors why did they do
it is because their childhood I don't
know maybe it's good they wanted to get
some you know like I don't I
some people would say that's extremely
naive to me it accords with virtually
everything I know about human beings and
how they behave but that doesn't explain
the disparity between different groups
which is what we're really talking about
sure I mean listen the the the causal
the causal chain can just as easily go
in the opposite direction crime causes
poverty last time I checked if you know
if you if you live in a criminal in a
neighborhood with a high crime rate good
luck getting a loan for your small
business good luck getting what anyone
to invest good luck getting people to
want to move to the area and therefore
raising property values and making
everyone richer what we call
gentrification is really just a synonym
for the crime rate in a formerly high
crime neighborhood going down so the
neighborhood becoming more desirable and
property values rising comment on it
sorry to drop what all I'm trying to dig
into is why is it that crime in those
communities is so much higher than
another's if it's not the history of
racism what is it so I mean I'm
objecting to the question a little bit
because of in what two groups is the
crime rate ever equal why do white white
people commit so much more crime than
Asians because white men seem evil we
know that but it is what I'm saying
people people have this expectation that
every group should have like identical
statistics and then when they see a
disparity they go oh my god why why is
there such a large disparity and me
looking at the data all I see is
disparity if I look at that if I compare
Jews to Protestants you're damn sure I'm
finding a wealth disparity there I'm
sorry that's just the truth but I'm not
asking why why why is if every deviation
from equality has some nefarious
explanation it's because we're lizards
made that's why do better but that's
just you know that's a David Icke theory
anyway
go ahead me so common what I really
enjoyed about this interview is that
we're talking and that you're bringing
nuance to the conversation you talk why
is it that we can't have these
conversations anymore in the mainstream
media if we try and do this and you know
the UK mainstream media or America
wherever it may be
it would degenerate into finger-pointing
talking over one another why have we
lost that ability frankly I'm not so
sure we ever had it I don't know if we
ever had it in my lifetime but yeah I
don't know the short answer is I don't
know you know mainstream media outlets
select for people who make points that
feel good that that preach to the choir
that are that don't involve any
statistics because people don't want to
hear numbers ever they want to hear
short sound bites and maybe at most a
story and anyone who wants to get more
complex than that is gonna find him or
herself relegate it to not cost like
this pumpkins like this is what you end
up in it yeah and that's not so bad I
mean listen in in a free market there's
there you know everyone can find their
niche but yeah it just means that you
know the the most mainstream outlets
sort of have to cater to the common
denominator and I think we kind of get
the media we deserve so how do we move
on Coleman because I mean look does you
say half your country is burning we're
not quite there and hopefully we won't
get there but a lot of people are
starting to feel like the veneer of
civilization is fraying at the edges how
do we move past these issues well I
would say first of all you know always
take note that things are not as bad as
they seem
you know the riots in Minneapolis were
horrible especially in a few other
cities and a lot of damage was done but
civilization I don't think is yet
fraying at the edges I think we have to
guard against the very bad ideas like
dismantling the police and I think we
will I don't think people will stand for
it I think we have to push for the
reasonable reforms of the police that we
ought to have done a while ago and above
all we have to make sure that you know
we are educated ourselves make sure you
you know what's going on don't just
listen don't just you know listen to
everything that you hear you know pick
your battles but stand up for yourself
when it matters and you know I'm not
sure I have much more advice to give
than that I like the points you make um
and there's a part of me and Barry mind
I'm a rabid pessimist so take this on
board but I just see a lot of people
been really scared to voice their
opinion through it in case they say the
wrong thing in case they express an
opinion clumsily which can then be
twisted and distorted and interpreted as
racism and all the rest of it do you
think that we are gonna come to a point
where debate is simply going to shut
down because people are too scared to
speak I mean I think we're kind of
already at that point yeah I think there
are there have to be tens of thousands
of people just in the u.s. that are
horrified to say what they really think
even if they only have tentative
opinions if they only half thinks
something they're terrified to say to
say what they think it's a lot more than
a few tens of thousands it's it's going
to be in the millions
I would suggest yeah probably yeah
probably yeah listen they're afraid to
lose their jobs they're afraid to lose
their friends they're afraid to lose
their relationships they're afraid to
lose everything
and you know there's very you know it
only really goes one way
if you say defund the police right now
post that on your Facebook despite how
insanely radical that that idea is
you're not really gonna lose very much
because of it your company's not going
to fire you you know maybe if you live
in a really red conservative bubble
which many people do yeah maybe you'll
face some consequences but if you live
in a city if you live you know anywhere
close to blue America you know you'll
face no consequences for that but you'll
you might lose everything if you if you
say the opposite if you so much as
express a skeptical word about black
lives matter so yeah it's it's it's it's
extremely tough we're living in we're
living through a moral panic one of the
great moral panics of American history
about racism and white supremacy and do
you think sorry carry on Colman no no go
and do you think it's almost in the
sense of like McCarthyism in that people
were just getting out and left Ryan
Center is being racist you know you you
I mean white privilege you can agree you
can disagree whatever it may be but if
you openly criticize white privilege
we've seen incidences in the UK of you
know newscasters getting yanked and then
having to give groveling public
apologies and all the rest of it hell no
I mean that yeah McCarthyism is one of
the one of the nicest analogies for
what's happening right now we look back
on the McCarthy era and we say how could
they have been so out of their minds
with regard to this communist threat you
know anytime someone was accused of
being a communist and a friend came to
his his defense and said what hate him
wait a minute guys look look at the
details here okay he was a little bit of
a socialist but if you actually look at
what he wrote he was you know he
condemned Stalin and yada yada yada
people weren't people wouldn't hear it
they would just ask which side are you
on as if that's the only you know
question that matters and that's what
you're seeing right now come on I was
gonna wrap up here but actually I want
to ask you about this defund the police
thing and the slogan because I've been
in arguments with people over this words
like you I've said look this
a crazy idea one of the things if you
get rid of the police one of the things
that will happen is there'll be more
crime in those communities and more
black people will die see if you believe
that as I do that the lives of black
people matter this is this is gonna
achieve the opposite of that right and
the argument that people make to me well
defund the police doesn't mean abolish
the police
it just means you know get rid of the
the militarized weaponry that you talked
about or whatever light is that true
people mean it in different ways yes
some people just mean get rid of
military militarized weapons you know
which is a very misleading it's very
misleading banner to put on that idea
wouldn't say reformed the police if
that's what you meant right you you
would I mean again defund the police is
a slogan and people are as they often do
they're saying it before they know what
it means they're saying it because it
sounds radical and cool and it makes
them seem really radical to their
friends so whatever I don't know they
can get laid more often or whatever but
and then you know is it one article yeah
look at him he's excited listen man if
it didn't work people wouldn't do it
okay cool nice one comon thanks man
but they're coming out with what it
means you know slowly and after the fact
so some people yes some people do want
to abolish the police hmm that's
ridiculous
some people want to replace the police
with Community Police so get rid of all
the cops with badges and we're gonna
build an institution that ourself we're
gonna train them better so that these
kinds of incidents never happened I
think that's extremely naive you know
you know the medical profession kills
hundreds of thousands of people every
year with medical errors but no one is
suggesting we just dismantle or get rid
of doctors and surgeons and Mike replace
them with our own system it's kind of
ridiculous because a lot of the problems
are inherent in the job itself no matter
who you get to be the police when you
come across a suspect of a violent crime
a lot of times they're going to resist
arrest
sometimes they're gonna pull a gun on
you doesn't matter who you are it
doesn't matter if you have the badge or
if you're
the new blacklivesmatter community
policeman so we might as well work with
the system we have now and reform it now
absolutely and it also doesn't take into
account like the human element of it
like whatever I was a former teacher
whatever industry or profession there is
you're gonna get good people and you're
gonna get people who are no good and
going to it for the wrong reasons every
teacher knows one teacher who was a
bully and used to bully the children and
it's awful but that's how it is and I
imagine if you're somebody who likes to
feel paralyzed to bully others and a
police officer is a pretty good job to
have Frances let's not talk about your
career mate but do you think that's it
that's a point as well commenting back
can we ever truly eradicate these things
because they're ingrained in our nature
yeah I mean this comes back to having
you know fundamentally different views
of of you know man as a creature some
people think that all of our four goals
and flaws are a consequence of bad ideas
and bad policies that if we can only get
the right set of policies and you know
ideas and raise children believing the
right things then there would be no
murder no rape no no war no anything
that we would truly achieve a utopia and
so they measure our society currently
against the imagined utopia that they
have in their minds and they always find
our society to be to be lacking other
people like myself are more persuaded by
the idea that human nature is a mixed
bag like other animals we come with a
built-in set of tendencies some of those
tendencies are good we love our families
we love our friends we have an empathy
we can see someone else's suffering and
feel it as our own but we also have
greed and the capacity for cruelty and
the desire to climb the ladder at other
peoples expense the desire to be mean
for no reason if you have never felt
these failings in yourself then
I you know I've ever become more
self-aware or thank your lucky stars
that you're like you know one of the few
humans that was just born and they'd be
perfect listen you look at every Society
in history it's had it's had a you know
there have been men even worse than
others but there have been none that
were perfect hmm I'm sorry there's been
none with no racism as long as there was
a snick difference there was bigotry
ethnic bigotry as long as there were men
and women there were sexism almost
always directed at women there was
violence in every society we've ever
seen so I either that's a coincidence
and humans have just been getting the
wrong answer to the question of what
ideas to raise our children with every
single time or there's something baked
into us by evolution that includes both
good qualities and bad qualities and the
institutions that allow us to make moral
progress are the ones that recognize
human nature as fixed and try to allow
us to make progress without having to be
Saints because we're never going to be
Saints it's a really brilliant point on
which to wrap up the interview oh man
you're a voice that needs to be heard
more of in this conversation and people
like you I think actually the kind of
people that can take our society forward
rather than the people who are burning
down buildings and tearing things down
so thank you for coming on the show
we've got one more question for you and
it's a question we always in the show
column which is what is the one thing
that we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be I
suppose that the answer is in America
the answer is homicide and violent crime
at a time like this it is more important
than ever even though it will seem
completely tone-deaf to people to remind
the American
population that homicide is the number
one cause of death for black men in
their 20s that is not true of any other
race that it's a first-order problem not
just in terms of the lives lost but in
terms of the cycle of poverty and
unemployment that plagues high crime
communities the fact that stores have to
charge higher prices to defray security
costs the fact that it's very hard to
attract investment property values are
low because no one wants to be in a
place that's unsafe every every problem
that a person of goodwill would want to
see salt is made worse by the reality of
violent crime in pockets of US cities
and suburbs the police are one of the
best tools we have one of the primary
tools we have to lower crime rate
they're not the only ones social
programs matter too but we have to keep
that in view as a central problem and
that can't be lost it's much easier to
focus on the police's villains it's easy
they're wearing badges I mean when in
every Hollywood movie that the guy with
the badge comes and stomps on someone
and you know you feel reflexive sympathy
as you should for the person being
stomped on and but you know society is
not always a Hollywood movie
sometimes the main villains are a small
subset of criminals in a population that
are wreaking havoc for everybody else so
that's what I would say already Coleman
thank you very much for coming on just
tell everybody by your podcast and where
they can follow your writing as well my
podcast has conversations with Coleman
you can listen to it wherever you're
wherever you listen to podcasts and you
can follow me on twitter at cold x man
perfect then we'll make sure we'll put
all those links in the video and in the
audio
description Coleman thank you so much
for coming on once again and thanks
everybody for watching and listening
we'll see you again very very soon with
another interview or a live stream take
care and see you soon guys thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
youtube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word